michael sheen we're talking about him  now he is from wales very fancy very  fast and you call him your nickname for  him is fancy isn't it you call him fancy  well to me anyone from Britain is fancy  I'm from Boston but also like he's the  first person I ever met that said things  like I need more pocket squares what is  a pocket square but it's that thing that  goes in here oh I know yeah thank you're  not wearing ya know you got a big  scratch to have those now feet of me  like he can say Shakespeare you know I'm  sorry you were gonna say no no I was I  was just curious I'm just so he can  exactly recite Shakespeare yeah at night  I'll be like say Shakespeare and he'll  be like I'm not your puppet and then  I'll go I know you just don't remember  then he's like you know either of us now  are saying in each Shakespeare who says  say Shakespeare this guy like give me a  little richer that takes a Shakespeare  thanks Jake spear  you